[Music]
hello and welcome to the Google Cloud
Advance network security demo Series
today we are going to talk about Cloud
FAL plus my name is Megan Yahya and I'm
a product manager at Google cloud and
I'm here with Nicholas bedart who's a
customer engineer we have heard from
many of our customers about the
importance of network threat detection
and prevention in their Cloud
environment as a must have for
protecting their workloads as we talked
with more customers it was clear that
they had three core areas of need when
it came to network threat detection and
prevention the first was the need for
complete visibility and control as they
transition from primarily perimeter
based inspection to inspecting traffic
within their Cloud environment and
really what they want is to do that even
between the workloads it is also
important to be able to prevent threats
even if the threats are
encrypted second our customers asked us
for a solution that was easy to deploy
and manage it was clear that they didn't
want to roll up their own Solutions
manage and scale fleets of workloads or
have to deal with bringing their own
open- source rules they wanted a fully
managed solution and finally they were
not willing to compromise on security
efficacy with the increasing
sophistication of stress and the massive
volume of new malare variants being
introduced every day they absolutely
needed a system that provided amazing
protection proven detection and
inspection capabilities with very low
noise today we are introducing Google
Cloud firewall plus which is a cloud
native an easy and fast to deploy
product it provides you with scalability
and performance as well as as
availability and reliability our
intrusion prevention capabilities are
built on top of the existing stateful
and distributed Cloud firewall which
enables users to leverage the
hierarchical policies and IM IM back
tags providing them with flexible
insertion with no need for rerouting or
reconfiguration we're using a new
technology called packet intercept that
is part of Google software defined
networking to redirect traffic flows to
firewall endpoints that are located in
the same Zone as the workload this helps
bring detection and prevention as close
to the workload as possible providing
north south and east west visibility and
control next to the VM interface level
we have partnered with PA Alto networks
Technologies to make sure we are not
compromising on security efficacy and
protect you against any kind of exploits
threats and command and control attacks
from day one we have built-in TLS
inspection capabilities to make sure no
threats go undetected we provide you
with the alerts in the UI as well as in
Cloud logging which provides you with
apis with that I pass it to Nicholas to
walk you through more information about
the underlying architecture and a
demo thank you Megan to configure
firewall plus with IP s you will need to
follow these steps first we need to
enable one firewall endpoint and attach
it to your VPC the firewall endpoint is
a Google manage poto Network BM that
provides firewall and inion Prevention
Services second you will need to create
a threat prevention security profile
this is where you will specify the
action to take on traffic that matches
specific threats signatures or severity
level you can allow deny or alert on
traffic third you will need to create a
security profile Group Security profile
group will be applied onto firewall
policies and in step four you will need
to enable Cloud firewall plus IPS into
the firewall
policies step number five you will be
able to view all of the threat logs in
firewall manager or in Cloud
login step number one two and three must
be done at the organization level
where step number four can be done at
both or level or at the project
level finally you can send the threat
lugs to your Security operation tool
using a log sync and Pub sub or the
chronical native
integration I would also like to bring
to your attention that enabling Cloud
firewall plus IPS will not require any
architecture change so no special
routing no special load balancing to
change in your existing top apology
Google take care of this in the back end
all you need to do is to turn it on on
your existing security policy now let's
get into my demo lab it's built over
three main components number one is a
Google Cloud project with two virtual
machines one web server VM and one
compromised
VM and second we have a cloud firewall
plus endpoint with IPS
configuration finally we have Security
operation tools using Chronicle Sim and
theur the web server is accessible
internally and from the internet using
an application load balancer and
cloudnet the compromised VM will attack
the web server from both the internet
and from the internal Network so this
will demonstrate spall plus capability
to protect against North South as well
as east west traffic the firewall
policies will capture VM traffic and
send it to the firewall endpoint for
threat
inspection the firewall endpoint will
apply the security profile actioned and
signature over ride and then send back
the payload to the destination alert or
block the
traffic it will also send all of the
logs to Cloud login where logging sync
will forward them to pubsub in order to
push to external security tool for
chronicle it's even faster as the
firewall logs are exported Auto
automatically at the org level using a
onetime access code option and the
chronical page within the Google Cloud
console this will allow my Security
operation team to collect and analyze
the threat logs to detect and response
to
incident you can also send all of these
logs to bigquery and create analytics
dashboard using the looker block that
are published on the
marketplace in this demonstration I will
first create a security profile in in
Alert model only I will also show you
how to overwrite the action for a
specific signature then I will change a
security profile from alert to block
mode in order to demonstrate how
firewall plus can now block
threats now let's go into the console
and see how we can achieve this
configuration in my console step number
one is to enable the firewall endpoint
and Associate it with the proper Network
VPC so
in the menu on the left you now see that
firewall plus has new options available
threats firewall and point and security
profiles firewall end point and security
profile has to be configured at the or
level so let's go and create the
firewall endpoint in order to do that
you simply need to click create and
select the region The Zone and give it a
name in my case it's already
done
then the second step is to associate a
VPC to it if we go into the VPC menu you
will find a new menu here saying called
firewall endpoint into that firewall
endpoint menu you will have an an option
to add a firewall endpoint Association
this is where you're going to associate
your org level firewall endpoint to your
VPC level project so simply click add
endpoint select the region The Zone and
in the list you will select the firewall
endpoint that you previously
configured so now that is done let's go
to step two step two is to create
security
profile in order to create security
profile we click in the security profile
menu on the left and you will have two
options security profiles and security
profile groups so step two is to create
security profile in this case I already
created created two security profile one
in alert and one in block
mode Let's go and review the security
the configuration for this security
profile as you can see we have two
option when we configure a security
profile we have security overrides and
we have signatures override security
override is where you tell what is the
over action that you want to take when a
specific threat or Runner relas is being
observed by IPS so in my case in my lab
I want to alert on everything to
start but I want to block any log 4J
threats so what I did is I configured
from
informational to critical the security
the severity override and I set that to
alert and the signature override I I
used three distinct signature that are
known to be log for Js attacked and I
configured them as a Deni
action if I go back and click to the
block
menu for for the security profile you
will see that I configured everything
from informational to critical to deny
and this time I don't have any signature
overr right I don't need them because I
already block I'm already blocking
everything on the signature over
right so now that my two security
profiles are
configured let's see how we can use them
in the firewall policies in order to use
them in the firewall policies you need
to create a security profile group the
security profile group will be the one
used in the firewall policy but you need
to attach it to a threat prevention
profile so in this case to start the
demo I Associated the Alert security
profile with my profile group number one
and I will reuse them in the firewall
policy uh right after so now that that's
being done let's go in the firewall
policy menu and see how we can use
it so if we go into the
firewall uh policies menu you can see
all of the rules that I created in order
to have my lab
working there is two use cases that I
want to demonstrate today in this demo
and it is the ability of firewall Plus
to block threat coming from external as
well as
internal for these two specific use case
I created two security policies the
number 800 and number 900 one to allow
Ingress one to allow Ingress
traffic coming from the internal and the
other one to allow a Ingress traffic
coming from the external in this case
the external being my cloudnet Gateway
so as you can see this is a typical
firewall rule where the action is either
allow or
deny this is no different for these two
rules I want to allow it right now but I
want now to inspect it so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to ins I'm going to
update these two
rules in order to have the traffic
inspected by firewall plus IPS so when
we see the action on on Match menu has
changed a bit with firewall plus we now
have a menu called proceed to L7
inspection so for this rule I'm going to
change
it to this new Option and I'm going to
select the security profile group one
that I created previously so I'm now
going to select this one
here and I'm going to change the other
one as
well here proceed to L7 inspection
security profile group and then
save now I have my two rules that are
showing proceed to layer s inspection
instead of allow so we can if I refresh
my my page
here we'll be able to see that instead
of having an allow we have proceed to L7
inspection with the proper security
profile group
now let me generate some threats in the
back end in order to kick in these two
rules okay the trats are generated let's
see in the trat menu how it looks like
so if I click in the menu Cloud firewall
threats I get to this page where I see
the details of everything that was
triggered by firewall plus I can see the
severity the time stamp the threat name
as well as the type and some information
if we go back if we go to the right we
will see that all of the action that my
threats generated are alert instead oh
we see one that is dropped let's go and
see okay this one that was dropped is an
Apache log forj exactly what I asked the
security profile to do so it is alerting
everything but blocking Apache log forg
now what happen if I want to block
everything instead of going into this
firewall policy again the only thing I
need to do is to change the security
profile within the profile group so
let's let's go back into the menu and
I'm going to change from alert to
deny so if I click this and I click edit
instead of alert I'm going to select the
block security profile and
see what it's doing
so I simply update this one and I'm
going to regen once it's done I'm going
to regenerate my threat so let's
regenerate the threat in the back end
that's done now I'm going to go back in
the threat menus and see what is the
result of this
modification you can see that we have
the same menu but if we scroll to the
left now all of the threats are now set
to action drop the log for J1 and the
other one that I used so this is exactly
working as expected so I was not forced
to change the firewall policy I only
needed to change the policy group then
it it had an impact on the uh the the
flow of traffic that was allow or
block now if I want to see uh uh all of
these logs in the
console what I can do is I can click
view audit log which will bring me to
the uh Cloud logging menu and I will be
able to see the full Json payload of
this specific threat so if I go there
and I expand this I will have all of the
detail that is required for me to do
some incident response so so all of the
data that will be eventually sent to my
SIM my sore or to Chronicle you can have
access to all of this in cloud lugin
from cloud lugin you can even create the
log routing sync directly from the menu
and then you will be able to send it to
your sim or your
sore so that's it thanks for watching to
learn more about Cloud firewall plus
please check out the documentation Link
in the
description